Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Why does some people scarf down anchovies by the pound while others recoil at the thought of a tuna fish sandwich? Why do the textures of certain foods like mushrooms turn people off? Not only is taste a biologically complex experience, it is quite psychological. Our guest for this episode is psychologist Dr. Linda Bartaschuk, an international leader in taste research, who is the Bushnell professor of food science and human nutrition at the University of Florida and director for the psychophysical research at the University's Center for
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。为什么有些人能大口大口地吃凤尾鱼，而另一些人一想到金枪鱼三明治就退避三舍？为什么蘑菇等某些食物的质地会让人们感到反感？味觉不仅是一种生物学上的复杂体验，更是一种心理体验。本期节目的嘉宾是心理学家琳达·巴塔舒克博士，她是味觉研究领域的国际领军人物，也是佛罗里达大学食品科学与人类营养学系的布什内尔教授，以及该校心理物理学研究中心的主任。
Smell and Taste. She's known for her discovery of supertasters, people who have more taste buzz than the average person, her work on enhancing the flavor of tomatoes, and for discovering a condition known as Burning Mouth Syndrome. Dr. Bartaschuk is joining us via Skype from the University of Florida. Welcome. Hi. So it may be surprising to people that taste is as psychological as it is biological. Can you explain how taste is studied from a psychological perspective? Well, taste is both biology and experience. And it's psychological because of the learning that we do. We learn to like things. Some of our liking or disliking is built into the brain, but most of it is learned. Does that explain why some people like very polarizing foods, like vegetamite, durians,
该中心专注于嗅觉和味觉研究。她因发现“超级味觉者”（即味觉感受比普通人更敏锐的人）而闻名，她在提升番茄风味方面的研究以及对“口腔灼烧综合征”的发现也广为人知。巴塔舒克博士正通过Skype从佛罗里达大学与我们连线。欢迎您。你好。人们可能会惊讶于味觉既是生物学上的，也是心理学上的。您能解释一下如何从心理学角度研究味觉吗？嗯，味觉既是生物学，也是一种体验。它之所以是心理学，是因为我们在这个过程中进行了学习。我们学会了喜欢某些东西。我们的一些喜好或厌恶是与生俱来的，但大部分是后天习得的。这能解释为什么有些人喜欢像维吉麦酱、榴莲这样极具争议的食物吗？
those really stinky cheeses. Is that genetic, cultural, or is it based on personal preference? A lot of that is early experience. They learn to like it very early. Their culture promotes it. They learned it from their parents. And what we learn to like when we experience it very early in life sticks with us. And so what if you hated, say, broccoli growing up, but now all of a sudden as an adult, you can't get enough. Are there changes in the taste psychology over time? The changes over time, some of it's biological, again, there are changes with aging, but most of it is just the experience you accumulate and probably you didn't switch from disliking broccoli to liking it a lot. It was probably gradual. And it probably happened because you paired broccoli with a lot of things you did like. And so you learned it almost accidentally as you were eating things you liked a lot. And so what causes certain food textures to bother? people. You know, for example, I like bananas, but sometimes the texture just makes me want to gag. No, texture is interesting. In fact, if you lecture to students and you mention texture
那些气味非常浓烈的奶酪。这是遗传、文化，还是基于个人偏好？很大程度上取决于早期的经历。他们很早就学会了喜欢这些东西。他们的文化推崇这些食物，他们是从父母那里学来的。我们在生命早期体验并学会喜欢的东西会伴随我们一生。那么，如果你小时候讨厌西兰花，但成年后突然变得非常爱吃，这该怎么解释？味觉心理会随时间发生变化吗？随着时间的推移，这种变化部分是生物学上的，毕竟衰老会带来变化，但大部分只是你积累的经验。你可能并不是从讨厌西兰花突然转变为非常喜欢它，这个过程很可能是渐进的。这很可能是因为你把西兰花和你喜欢的很多东西搭配在一起吃。所以，你在吃自己喜欢的东西时，几乎是无意中学会了喜欢它。那么，是什么导致某些食物的质地让人们感到困扰呢？你知道，比如我喜欢香蕉，但有时它的质地让我感到恶心。不，质地很有趣。事实上，如果你给学生讲课并提到质地，
and you say there are textures, some people don't like, you can actually watch people's faces get red in the audience. It's embarrassing. It's emotional. And we don't understand that very well. For example, you know the little curly thing next to an egg yolk? I can't stand that. If I get that with my egg, I don't want to eat the rest of it. And I don't generally admit that because people think it's a little weird. Texture reversions are considered rather strange. We don't talk about them much. But they are quite common, though, you said, right? They're very common. And why is really a puzzle because they don't really have nutritional consequences. So something else is going on, and that is something that hasn't been studied much. I'd really like to know more
你说有些质地是人们不喜欢的，你真的可以看到听众的脸变红。这很尴尬，也很情绪化。我们对这一点了解得还不够透彻。例如，你知道鸡蛋黄旁边那个小小的卷曲的东西吗？我受不了那个。如果我的鸡蛋里有那个，我就不想吃剩下的部分了。我通常不会承认这一点，因为人们会觉得这有点奇怪。对质地的排斥被认为相当古怪。我们很少谈论它们。但你刚才说，它们其实很常见，对吧？它们非常普遍。为什么会这样确实是个谜，因为它们并没有真正的营养后果。所以肯定还有其他原因，而这一点还没有被深入研究。我自己也非常想了解更多。
about it myself. Many of us probably have that person in our lives who only likes, or maybe we are that person who only likes brown food or white food, so that's pasta, potatoes, chicken, or whatever. So what causes people to be picky eaters? Wow. Picky eaters is really a loaded subject, especially with parents. Occasionally, I have a parent or grandparent bringing a child to me because they're upset because the kid is a picky eater.
很多人的生活中可能都有这样的人，或者我们自己就是这样的人：只喜欢棕色食物或白色食物，比如意大利面、土豆、鸡肉等等。那么，是什么导致人们变得挑食呢？哇。挑食是一个非常沉重的话题，尤其是对父母而言。偶尔会有父母或祖父母带孩子来找我，因为他们很苦恼，觉得孩子挑食。
And they think the kid must be a supertaster. and that explains it. So they come to me in the hopes that I can verify that there's something going on. The truth is we're all picky eaters to start with. We learn to accept things, but if you look at the way we acquire preferences from the time we're babies, for example, vegetables are really, really slow to develop preference for. And one of the reasons is you don't get much immediate reward from a vegetable. things that have fat in them, you get an immediate calorie load, things that are sweet or salty,
他们认为孩子一定是“超级味觉者”，并以此来解释这种行为。所以他们来找我，希望我能证实这背后是否有某种原因。事实是，我们一开始都是挑食者。我们学会去接受事物，但如果你观察我们从婴儿时期开始获得偏好的方式，例如，对蔬菜产生偏好真的非常非常缓慢。原因之一是你从蔬菜中得不到多少即时的奖励。而含有脂肪的食物，你会获得即时的热量补充；甜味或咸味的食物，
you've got hardwired liking built into your brain. But vegetables don't buy you much. So we really are acquiring our liking for foods, one food at a time, except for sweet and salty, which we like as soon as we can perceive them. And that learning liking just takes time. Now, why does some people develop such dislikes? That's actually a wonderful question. And part of it can do with gastrointestinal illness.
你的大脑中内置了对它们的喜爱。但蔬菜给不了你太多东西。所以我们确实是在一点一点地培养对食物的喜爱，除了甜味和咸味，因为我们一旦能感知到它们就会喜欢。这种学习喜好的过程需要时间。那么，为什么有些人会产生如此强烈的厌恶感呢？这其实是一个很好的问题。部分原因可能与胃肠道疾病有关。
For example, if a small child tends to get nauseated frequently and throw up, anything that you eat when you're experiencing nausea is likely to be learned as disgusting very, very quickly. It's one trial learning. So sometimes people have aversions to it. a lot of foods because they got sick a lot as a baby. When you don't have that kind of history or can't remember it, sometimes it can be very puzzling to explain. But I'll tell you, one thing don't do. If you've got a picky kid, don't bug them about it.
例如，如果一个小孩子经常感到恶心并呕吐，那么你在感到恶心时吃的任何东西，都很容易被迅速地学会并产生厌恶感。这是一种“一次性学习”。所以有时人们会对很多食物产生厌恶，因为他们小时候经常生病。当你没有那样的经历或者记不清时，有时很难解释原因。但我告诉你，有一件事千万别做。如果你的孩子挑食，不要为此去烦他们。
Don't insist they eat things they don't like and don't make a big fuss about it because you're going to create a problem that you're then really going to require professional help to solve. So if you do want to get a picky eater to eat more vegetables or fruit, let's say, but might be difficult, is there a way you can try to, instead of forcing them to eat something like that, you know, find a way to show them how good it can taste or hide vegetables or fruit in other foods? Is that possible? You know, one of the best ways to get a kid to try something new to eat is to have another kid at the table eat it. Now, when that's not practical, there is another
不要强迫他们吃不喜欢的东西，也不要大惊小怪，因为你会制造出一个问题，到时候真的需要专业帮助才能解决。那么，如果你想让一个挑食的孩子多吃蔬菜或水果，但这可能很困难，有没有什么方法可以尝试，而不是强迫他们吃，比如找到一种方法向他们展示这些食物有多好吃，或者把蔬菜或水果藏在其他食物里？这可能吗？你知道，让孩子尝试新食物的最好方法之一，就是让餐桌上的另一个孩子吃它。当这不切实际时，还有另一个
solution. For example, you want a kid to eat broccoli. Serve it with something good on it, like sprinkle a little sugar on it, put something fat on it, add butter to it, add cheese. The beauty is that our learning theorist experts tell us that the kid will acquire a preference for the flavor of the broccoli because it's paired with something that's really highly liked. Later on, when you take that highly liked substance away, the flavor preferences remain. So you can actually condition a preference to something like the flavor of broccoli by adding sugar to it. And later when you take the sugar away, you still have the broccoli preference. That must be an interesting taste to have some sugar on your broccoli, right?
解决方案。例如，你想让孩子吃西兰花。在上面加点好吃的，比如撒点糖，加点脂肪，加点黄油，加点奶酪。妙处在于，我们的学习理论专家告诉我们，孩子会因为西兰花与他们非常喜欢的食物搭配在一起，从而对西兰花的味道产生偏好。稍后，当你把那些他们非常喜欢的配料拿走时，对西兰花的偏好依然会保留。所以，你实际上可以通过加糖来调节对西兰花味道的偏好。之后当你去掉糖时，他们依然会喜欢西兰花。西兰花上加点糖，那味道一定很有趣，对吧？
Well, you know, dietitians tend to be very bothered by the instructions like this. But sugar is not the evil that we tend to make it out to be. We evolved with sugar. Frankly, artificial sweeteners worry me a lot more. How come? Why do you think they're so much worse than regular sugar? Well, first of all, they have a lot of toxic. is associated with them. It concerns me that we tend not to pay attention to some of the
嗯，你知道，营养学家往往对这样的建议感到非常困扰。但糖并不是我们通常认为的那种恶魔。我们是在糖的陪伴下进化的。坦率地说，人工甜味剂更让我担心。为什么？你为什么认为它们比普通糖糟糕得多？嗯，首先，它们有很多毒性与它们相关。让我担心的是，我们往往不注意一些关于这方面的
literature about this. For example, cyclimate was taken off the American market because it was found to be carcinogenic. Well, it turns out that probably wasn't correct, but saccharin is known to be mildly carcinogenic, and there it stays. Because at the time, people tried to get it off the diet. it was about the only artificial sweetener out there. And people who thought they needed artificial sweeteners really raised a row about it. So it's probably almost better if you can, I mean, unless you're diabetic or some other physical need to have regular sugar on your food. Just don't have a lot of it.
文献。例如，甜蜜素被撤出美国市场，因为它被发现具有致癌性。嗯，事实证明这可能并不准确，但糖精被认为是轻微致癌的，可它依然存在。因为当时人们试图把它从饮食中剔除时，它是市面上几乎唯一的人工甜味剂。那些认为自己需要人工甜味剂的人确实为此闹得不可开交。所以，如果你能做到的话，除非你是糖尿病患者或有其他生理需求必须摄入普通糖，否则最好还是少吃点。
Be careful about the quantities you eat. But a certain amount of sugar is really not a bad thing. You're right. If you're a diabetic, then you have to worry about it. This is one of the reasons that I'm interested, very much interested in research that might lead us to a sweetener that really is safe. I'm happy to tell you we're doing that right now. We're working on volatiles. Now, a volatile for people who aren't training chemistry. It's a compound that can be in gaseous form. Like you sniff something, a flower, the compounds that you're
注意你摄入的数量。但一定量的糖其实并不是坏事。你说得对。如果你是糖尿病患者，那么你确实需要担心它。这也是我非常关注那些可能引导我们找到真正安全甜味剂的研究的原因之一。我很高兴地告诉你，我们现在正在做这件事。我们正在研究挥发性物质。对于没有受过化学训练的人来说，挥发性物质是一种可以以气态形式存在的化合物。就像你闻某种东西，比如花，你闻到的那些化合物
smelling are volatiles. They're in gaseous form. The compounds that we sniff when we smell a fruit and are so pleasant, those are volatiles. Now those compounds, when you bite into that fruit, those compounds actually go in your mouth and they rise at the back of your mouth through a space up to the back of your nose. Think about post-nasal drip. That space that the post-nasal drip comes through
就是挥发性物质。它们以气态形式存在。当我们闻水果时闻到的那些令人愉悦的化合物，就是挥发性物质。现在，当你咬一口水果时，这些化合物实际上进入了你的口腔，并通过口腔后部的一个空间上升到鼻腔后部。想想鼻后滴漏。鼻后滴漏流经的那个空间
is what volatiles rise through. And so a volatile can bite in and the odorant, a volatile can rise at the back of your mouth and go into your nose from the rear. Now, when your brain detects a volatile coming in that path, it sends it to a part of the brain that also handles taste. And the two interact there. And there are some volatiles that actually intensify the taste message.
就是挥发性物质上升的通道。所以，挥发性物质可以被咬开，气味分子可以通过口腔后部上升并从后方进入你的鼻子。当你的大脑检测到挥发性物质通过这条路径进入时，它会将其发送到大脑中同样处理味觉的区域。两者在那里相互作用。有些挥发性物质实际上会增强味觉信息。
That's fascinating. And you, we raised a lot of really interesting points that I want to address in a couple different questions here, but just to wrap up the section about picky eaters, you know, why are some people more adventurous than others on the flip side of being a picky eater? Well, first of all, being adventurous is a more general characteristic of personality, and I honestly don't know what makes us more adventurous.
这太迷人了。你提出了很多非常有趣的观点，我想在接下来的几个问题中探讨一下，但先结束关于挑食者的部分，你知道，为什么有些人比其他人更爱冒险，而有些人则相反，是挑食者？嗯，首先，爱冒险是一种更普遍的人格特征，老实说，我不知道是什么让我们变得更爱冒险。
But if you want to become more adventurous in food, you have to go out and try new foods. This is something that I run into when I see a patient who's got taste damage and they can't taste things as well as they used to. I urge them to go out and try a lot of new things. And part of that is in the hope that they're going to find a few things. sensory inputs that are still going to be really good. But there's a hidden purpose to that. The hidden purpose is the more things you try, the more things you give your brain an opportunity to learn to like, you eat something. And the sensory signature of that, actually, the retronasal
但如果你想在食物上变得更爱冒险，你必须走出去尝试新食物。当我遇到味觉受损、无法像以前那样品尝食物的病人时，我经常会遇到这种情况。我敦促他们走出去尝试很多新东西。部分原因是希望他们能找到一些仍然感觉非常好的感官输入。但其中还有一个隐藏的目的。隐藏的目的是，你尝试的东西越多，你给大脑学习喜欢的机会就越多。你吃某种东西，它的感官特征，实际上是鼻后
olfaction, that message I was telling you that comes up the rear of the mouth, that is the signature of the food, the flavor of it. Your brain records that. And if that flavor is, coming into the brain at the same time, calories are coming in through your stomach, your brain is going to tell you to like that flavor. So the more different things you eat, the more unusual flavors you are pairing with calories and your brain is going to make you like them. That's fascinating. So there are ways to enhance what you like to eat just to give it a shot and try it and see if you can like it again. Okay. That's really interesting. The more you explore the food world, the more things you're going to learn to like. Now, you have to be careful.
嗅觉，也就是我刚才说的从口腔后部上升的信息，那是食物的特征，它的风味。你的大脑会记录下来。如果这种风味进入大脑的同时，热量也通过胃部进入，你的大脑就会告诉你去喜欢这种风味。所以你吃的不同东西越多，你搭配热量的异常风味就越多，你的大脑就会让你喜欢它们。这太迷人了。所以确实有方法可以增强你对食物的喜爱，只要试一试，看看能不能重新喜欢上它。好的。这真的很有趣。你探索的食物世界越多，你学会喜欢的东西就越多。现在，你必须小心，
because if you start out really disliking a lot of things, you can then expose yourself to things you don't like. And sometimes it'll backfire and you'll get to like it even less. So it's better to start off neutral and pair something with calories or good taste like sweet or salty and your brain will make you like it. And we've talked about smell a little bit. So can you talk about how integral smell is to the full sensory experience of food? So, you know, anyone who's ever had a cold, which is probably everyone who is listening,
因为如果你一开始就非常讨厌很多东西，你可能会让自己接触到更多你不喜欢的东西。有时这会适得其反，让你变得更讨厌它。所以最好从中性开始，把某种东西与热量或甜味、咸味等好味道搭配起来，你的大脑就会让你喜欢它。我们已经谈到了一点嗅觉。那么你能谈谈嗅觉对于食物的完整感官体验有多重要吗？所以，你知道，任何感冒过的人，可能是在座的每一位，
can attest to how bland and basically terrible food tastes when they're sick. Well, I mean, that's actually a myth. The notion that you can't perceive the flavor of food when you got a cold, there are some people that do lose the ability to smell because the area that the odorants have to go through to get to receptors get swollen from a cold. And the odors just don't get through the area. But that's not true for most people. For example, I don't lose a sense of smell at all when I get a cold. And I think most people don't.
都能证明当你生病时，食物尝起来是多么平淡，基本上是多么糟糕。嗯，我的意思是，那其实是一个神话。关于感冒时无法感知食物风味的说法，确实有些人因为感冒导致气味分子到达受体的区域肿胀，从而失去了嗅觉能力。气味确实无法通过该区域。但这并不适用于大多数人。例如，我感冒时根本不会失去嗅觉。我想大多数人也不会。
But unfortunately, there is a fairly rare condition where the virus itself can damage the olfactory system. And those people do lose smell with a cold, but it outlasts the cold. Oh, okay. But just smell in general. How is it, how integral is it to enjoying and tasting your food? It's extremely important. And let me first distinguish between taste and taste. smell because I think it's easier to understand all this if you really get that distinction.
但不幸的是，有一种相当罕见的疾病，病毒本身会损害嗅觉系统。这些人确实会因感冒而失去嗅觉，但这种影响会持续到感冒痊愈之后。哦，好的。但就嗅觉而言。它对于享受和品尝食物有多重要？它极其重要。首先，让我区分一下味觉和嗅觉，因为如果你真正理解了这种区别，我认为理解这一切会更容易。
Taste is what's coming from your tongue. Sweet, salty, sour, bitter, umami, if you buy the advertising stuff coming from places like Kajunomoto, which I do not. But the four basic taste, sweet, salty, sour, bitter coming from your tongue. Now, when you sniff with your nose, you're bringing volatiles, odorants, in through your nose, they have to go through a very small opening And that opening is what gets swollen during cold for some people. But once the volatile goes through that opening, it hits the receptors and sends a message to the brain. And that's smell. That's what we sniff from the outside world.
味觉来自你的舌头。甜、咸、酸、苦、鲜（如果你相信像味之素这类公司宣传的话，我个人不信）。但四种基本味觉：甜、咸、酸、苦来自你的舌头。现在，当你用鼻子嗅时，你通过鼻子吸入挥发性物质、气味分子，它们必须通过一个非常小的开口。对于某些人来说，这个开口在感冒时会肿胀。但一旦挥发性物质通过那个开口，它就会触及受体并向大脑发送信息。这就是嗅觉。这就是我们从外部世界闻到的东西。
But the nose has a second job. And that second job is you put food in your mouth, you bite into it, you chew it, you swallow it. And swallowing forces those volatiles up that passage at the back of the mouth that I mentioned. Now that input is going up and it's hitting, going to. through the same small opening going to the receptors. So you've got a molecule that you could sniff and it comes into your nose one way and that same molecule can go through a different pathway if you get it from your mouth. But the brain pays attention to the difference and it sends the input to different places in the brain. So when you sniff, the input goes to one area and we call it smell.
但鼻子还有第二个工作。第二个工作是：你把食物放进嘴里，咬它，咀嚼它，吞咽它。吞咽会迫使那些挥发性物质通过我提到的口腔后部的通道上升。现在，那个输入正在上升，它正在通过同样的那个小开口去触及受体。所以，你有一个分子，你可以通过鼻子以一种方式闻到它，而同样的分子如果你从嘴里摄入，它可以通过不同的路径。但大脑会注意到这种差异，并将输入发送到大脑的不同位置。所以当你嗅的时候，输入进入一个区域，我们称之为嗅觉。
You put food in your mouth, chew it, swallow it, and that odorous input goes to another part of the brain, and actually that input is what produces flavor. And flavor is going to the same part of the brain as taste, and they can interact. That was what I was mentioning earlier. Now, here's the key thing. We are hardwired. Our brains are wired to make us like sweet, sour, well, not sour so much for most people, but sweet, salty, and to dislike bitter. That's hardwired. But liking smells is entirely learned in humans. At least that's what we think so far. If there are any smells that we're born loving, we haven't identified them yet. Well, that's fascinating. So put this together for food. You've got taste, which is giving you hardwired affect plus or minus, and you've got
你把食物放进嘴里，咀嚼，吞咽，那个气味输入进入大脑的另一个部分，实际上那个输入才是产生风味的原因。风味进入的是与味觉相同的大脑部分，它们可以在那里相互作用。这就是我刚才提到的。现在，关键点在于：我们是天生的。我们的大脑被设定为让我们喜欢甜味、咸味，不喜欢苦味。这是天生的。但人类对气味的喜爱完全是后天习得的。至少到目前为止我们是这么认为的。如果有什么气味是我们天生就喜欢的，我们还没有发现。嗯，这太迷人了。所以把这些结合起来看食物。你有味觉，它给你天生的情感正负反馈；你有
smell, which is giving you learned affect. And that depends very much, and almost entirely, in fact, on your experience. Put it together and you've got food. It's complicated. Yes, it's very complex. And also, smell and taste is known to evoke powerful memories. So can you explain how that works as well? Not taste. Oh, not taste. Okay. It's smell that produces those memories. We call it the Proust effect, because Proust wrote about his Madelens with tea in his, I think, aunt's kitchen. And they brought back all these evocative memories. So yes, we associate emotion with smell very, very powerfully. and in fact it may be the most important phenomenon and maybe with the exception of being able to identify food by smell but having affective reactions to it controls a huge amount of our food behavior
嗅觉，它给你习得的情感反馈。这在很大程度上，实际上几乎完全取决于你的经验。把它们结合起来，你就得到了食物。这很复杂。是的，非常复杂。而且，嗅觉和味觉也被认为能唤起强烈的记忆。你能解释一下这是怎么运作的吗？不是味觉。哦，不是味觉。好的。是嗅觉产生了那些记忆。我们称之为“普鲁斯特效应”，因为普鲁斯特写过他在他姨妈厨房里吃玛德琳蛋糕蘸茶的经历。它们带回了所有这些唤起性的记忆。所以是的，我们将情感与嗅觉非常强烈地联系在一起。事实上，这可能是最重要的现象，也许除了能够通过嗅觉识别食物之外，对它产生情感反应控制了我们大量的饮食行为。
and going back to speaking about food in itself you know why do some foods like say fish sauce or anchovies like I mentioned so on their own most people don't like or many people don't like but if they're added to something they suddenly become delicious so like in Vietnamese food a fish sauce really enhances the flavors or an anchovies in a Caesar dressing can really make it taste really good. You explain how that works? Yeah. A lot of it's simple concentration.
回到谈论食物本身，你知道，为什么有些食物，比如鱼露或凤尾鱼，就像我提到的，单独吃时大多数人不喜欢，或者很多人不喜欢，但如果把它们加到别的东西里，它们突然就变得美味了？比如在越南菜中，鱼露确实增强了风味，或者凯撒酱里的凤尾鱼真的能让它尝起来非常好。你能解释一下这是怎么运作的吗？是的。很大程度上是简单的浓度问题。
That is, when you taste pure fish sauce, you're really getting a full dose. When you add it to food, it's both diluted by the food and it's diluted by the other sensory experience. That is when you put a whole bunch of tastes and smells together, they suppress each other. And what you end up with is an experience that is certainly not the linear sum of all the things that went into it. For example, imagine when you make a beautiful Chinese sauce to have on dumplings. You have soy sauce, maybe you add if you really love salt, salt, sugar, a little vinegar, you put all that together. And if you added those tastes and smells linearly, it would knock the top of your head off.
也就是说，当你品尝纯鱼露时，你确实摄入了一整份剂量。当你把它加到食物中时，它既被食物稀释了，也被其他感官体验稀释了。也就是说，当你把一大堆味道和气味放在一起时，它们会相互抑制。最终你得到的是一种体验，它肯定不是所有成分的线性总和。例如，想象一下当你制作一种美味的中国酱汁来蘸饺子时。你有酱油，如果你真的很喜欢盐，可能还会加盐、糖、一点醋，你把所有这些放在一起。如果你线性地添加这些味道和气味，它会让你头晕目眩。
So they suppress each other. So what happens when you eat food is it's all kept within a reasonable intensity domain. So it's really those chemicals reacting together and working together that make them taste really good once they're all mixed. Absolutely. And also you learn the mixture sensation. That is one of the beautiful things our brains do is to record information about what we've eaten before. And those are saved almost as like templates in the brain. So for example, look at bacon. You eat bacon, it's got protein in it, it's got fat in it. Those are two things that your brain perceives as really good. So it's going to make you love the flavor that comes in with bacon.
所以它们相互抑制。因此，当你吃食物时，一切都保持在合理的强度范围内。所以，一旦它们混合在一起，确实是那些化学物质相互反应并共同作用，使它们尝起来非常好。绝对是这样。而且你还学会了混合的感觉。这是我们大脑所做的美妙事情之一，即记录关于我们以前吃过什么的信息。这些信息几乎像模板一样保存在大脑中。例如，看看培根。你吃培根，它含有蛋白质，含有脂肪。这是你的大脑认为非常好的两样东西。所以它会让你爱上培根带来的风味。
Now, that flavor is actually a composite. It's a lot of salt. It's a variety. I mean, dozens of different volatiles make up the smell and the flavor of bacon. You put those all together, and they produce a template of certain sensory signature that's stored in your brain. And the next time you eat bacon, you're going to recognize it very quickly. Yeah, and people go wild for bacon these days, it seems like. Well, look what it's got in it.
现在，那种风味实际上是一个复合体。它有很多盐。它是一种多样性。我的意思是，几十种不同的挥发性物质构成了培根的气味和风味。你把它们放在一起，它们就产生了一个模板，一种存储在你大脑中的特定感官特征。下次你吃培根时，你会很快认出它。是的，现在人们似乎对培根非常疯狂。嗯，看看它里面有什么。
That protein, what's not to like? Exactly. Add a little sugar maybe from pancakes or something, maple syrup. Dangerous combination. And why do some people, can they tolerate super spicy foods? Like they can add the hottest hot sauce to their chili and love it or eat these ghost peppers and all sorts of things like that, but while other people can't even stand a hint of heat, some of my family members are like that, no heat at all on their food. Why is, why can some
那种蛋白质，有什么理由不喜欢呢？没错。再加点糖，也许来自煎饼或其他什么东西，枫糖浆。危险的组合。为什么有些人能忍受超级辛辣的食物？比如他们可以在辣椒里加最辣的辣酱，并且很喜欢，或者吃这些鬼椒和各种各样的东西，而另一些人甚至连一点点辣味都受不了？我的一些家人就是这样，他们的食物里一点辣味都不能有。为什么有些人
people eat really hot food and others can't? Some of it's genetic. For example, taste buds in your tongue are surrounded by a basket of pain fibers. So the more taste buds you've got, the more pain your tongue is capable of perceiving. Now, the number of taste buds you're born with is, under genetic control, at least in part. There may be several factors. So if you're born with a lot of taste buds, we call those people supertasters. You're also born with a very large number of pain fibers. And so you're going to feel the burn of a pepper about three times as much. And I love watching the food channel and you watch these pepper eating contests. The person who can eat that really powerful pepper, there are two factors. One of them is, they're probably.
能吃非常辣的食物，而另一些人不能？部分原因是遗传。例如，你舌头上的味蕾被一篮子痛觉纤维包围着。所以你拥有的味蕾越多，你的舌头能够感知的疼痛就越多。现在，你天生拥有的味蕾数量在一定程度上受遗传控制。可能有几个因素。所以如果你天生拥有很多味蕾，我们称这些人是“超级味觉者”。你也天生拥有大量的痛觉纤维。所以你会感觉到辣椒的灼烧感大约是普通人的三倍。我喜欢看美食频道，你看着这些吃辣椒比赛。那个能吃掉那种非常强力辣椒的人，有两个因素。其中之一是，他们可能
not a supertaster so they don't have the biology to perceive the pain as intense. But in addition, capsaicin is the compound that makes all chili peppers burn. And capsicin desensitizes pain receptors. So if you habitually eat chili pepper, you're desensitizing the pain receptors on your tongue. If you'd like to prove that yourself, go for a vacation, go for two weeks or so without eating any chili pepper, then come back and eat the amount you're used to eating, it will burn. And that relates to your taste buds regenerating over time, correct? No, there's no, regeneration is a natural part of the taste system, and all of our taste buds die off and regenerate. They don't even have a very long taste life. And burn doesn't actually
不是超级味觉者，所以他们没有那种能感知强烈疼痛的生物学基础。但此外，辣椒素是使所有辣椒产生灼烧感的化合物。而辣椒素会使痛觉受体脱敏。所以如果你习惯吃辣椒，你就是在使舌头上的痛觉受体脱敏。如果你想亲自证明这一点，去度假吧，两周左右不吃任何辣椒，然后回来吃你习惯吃的量，它会很辣。这与你的味蕾随时间再生有关，对吧？不，没有，再生是味觉系统的自然组成部分，我们所有的味蕾都会死亡并再生。它们的味觉寿命并不长。而且灼烧感实际上并不会
damage anything. I mean, it produces a powerful sensation of burn. But for the most part, things like capsaic and chili peppers do not actually produce any damage. But you said you just become desensitized to them over time. Yeah, you don't feel the burn. And that is really fun. For example, suppose you go to a restaurant and you order a hot dish and it's too hot for you. Fill your mouth with it. Really let the burn hit a maximum.
损坏任何东西。我的意思是，它产生了一种强烈的灼烧感。但在大多数情况下，像辣椒素和辣椒这样的东西实际上并不会产生任何损害。但你说过你只是随着时间的推移对它们脱敏了。是的，你感觉不到灼烧感了。这真的很有趣。例如，假设你去一家餐馆，点了一道辣菜，但它对你来说太辣了。让你的嘴里充满它。真正让灼烧感达到最大值。
And then sit and chat for a few minutes. You can drink ice water to keep the burn down while you're doing that. and the burn will naturally fade away in 10, 15 minutes. At the end of that fade, put the hot food back in your mouth, and it won't burn as much. You can desensitize your pain receptors on your tongue that fast. Wow, that is fascinating. I thought it would be like a gradual process, but it can be over the course of one meal. Nope, it can happen in really in minutes.
然后坐下来聊几分钟。你可以喝冰水来保持灼烧感，同时做这些事。灼烧感会在10到15分钟内自然消退。在消退结束时，把辣的食物放回嘴里，它就不会那么辣了。你可以那么快地让舌头上的痛觉受体脱敏。哇，这太迷人了。我以为这是一个渐进的过程，但它可以在一顿饭的过程中完成。不，它真的可以在几分钟内发生。
And speaking of the supertasters you just mentioned, so those are people with more taste buds. And while this sounds like a blessing in some ways, you also found that that may not be the case. So can you explain why? Well, it's, in terms of eating food, there's one thing about being a supertaster that really is wonderful. We discovered this fairly recently. That is the pleasure you get from your favorite foods is more intense if you're a supertaster. Now, we don't know why that is. This is why I think there's more to being a supertaster than just taste buds, because pleasure is happening in the brain. So something in the brain is different with supertasters,
说到你刚才提到的超级味觉者，他们是味蕾更多的人。虽然这在某些方面听起来是一种福气，但你也发现情况可能并非如此。你能解释一下为什么吗？嗯，在吃食物方面，成为超级味觉者有一点确实非常棒。我们最近才发现这一点。那就是如果你是超级味觉者，你从最喜欢的食物中获得的快乐会更强烈。现在，我们不知道为什么会这样。这就是为什么我认为成为超级味觉者不仅仅是因为味蕾，因为快乐发生在大脑中。所以超级味觉者的大脑中肯定有什么不同，
and they're getting more pleasure from their favorite foods. Now, that isn't the blessing you might think because the supertasters don't have quite as many favorite foods. There are also a lot of things they don't like to eat. They tend to be pickier eaters because they're very sensitive to bitter, for example. They don't like certain texture. Now, that's a case of where texture, there is certain, amount of biology in it, and texture is more intense to supertasters so they can be put off by it.
他们从最喜欢的食物中获得了更多的快乐。现在，这并不像你想象的那样是一种福气，因为超级味觉者并没有那么多最喜欢的食物。他们也有很多不喜欢吃的东西。他们往往更挑食，因为他们对苦味非常敏感，例如。他们不喜欢某种质地。现在，这是一个质地问题，其中有一定的生物学因素，而且质地对超级味觉者来说更强烈，所以他们可能会被它吓跑。
Yeah, and so for those supertasters, they may not be likely to eat said bitter things. Maybe they're not eating some of those cruciferous vegetables like Brussels sprouts and those things that can be very good for you, by the way. So that's the second piece of this. Your diet has, it involves risk factors for diseases. And one of the reasons we're very interested in the fact that there are supertasters is that their diets are affected. They don't choose to eat the same foods. And because of that, it changes their risk factors.
是的，所以对于那些超级味觉者来说，他们可能不太可能吃那些苦的东西。也许他们不吃一些十字花科蔬菜，比如抱子甘蓝，顺便说一句，这些东西对你非常有好处。所以这是第二部分。你的饮食涉及疾病的风险因素。我们对超级味觉者感兴趣的原因之一是他们的饮食受到了影响。他们不会选择吃同样的食物。正因为如此，它改变了他们的风险因素。
So, for example, colon cancer, one of the risk factors is fiber in your diet. Well, supertasters don't like eating highly textured foods as much as others. They eat fewer of them. And so they actually are at a slightly higher biological risk for colon cancer. Now, that's a small difference, but it's big enough that you can actually see it. We did a study, for example, looking colon polyps. Colon polyps are risk factor for colon cancer, and they're produced in people who don't consume enough fiber.
所以，例如，结肠癌，风险因素之一是饮食中的纤维。嗯，超级味觉者不像其他人那样喜欢吃高质地的食物。他们吃得更少。所以他们实际上患结肠癌的生物学风险略高。现在，这是一个很小的差异，但它足够大，以至于你实际上可以看到它。例如，我们做了一项研究，观察结肠息肉。结肠息肉是结肠癌的风险因素，它们产生于那些纤维摄入不足的人群中。
And if you look, in fact, at supertasters and people who are not supertasters, they have different number of colon polyps. The supertasters have more. switch to something else like head neck cancer. Now the risk factors are consumption of alcohol and smoking. And supertasters don't drink as much alcohol. They don't like it because it burns their tongues and doesn't taste very good. And they also don't like to smoke for sensory reasons as well.
如果你观察超级味觉者和非超级味觉者，他们有不同数量的结肠息肉。超级味觉者更多。转向其他疾病，比如头颈癌。现在的风险因素是饮酒和吸烟。而超级味觉者喝的酒不多。他们不喜欢它，因为它会灼伤他们的舌头，味道也不太好。而且由于感官原因，他们也不喜欢吸烟。
So the supertaster is an advantage when you look at head neck cancer. And is there's a genetic component to being a supertaster? is. We don't know how big it is. Nobody's done a family study on it yet, but it certainly is genetic. For example, if you look at the tongues of identical twins, they're going to look very, very similar. By the way, you can look at the tongue and see whether somebody's a supertaster. And your listeners can do this by going to the supermarket and buying blue food coloring. Bring it home, swab it on your tongue with a cue tip, and swallow a couple of times to move the dye around. your tongue, best to do it in a magnifying mirror with a flashlight. And what you'll see are pink
所以当你观察头颈癌时，超级味觉者是有优势的。成为超级味觉者有遗传成分吗？有。我们不知道它有多大。还没有人对此进行过家族研究，但它肯定是遗传的。例如，如果你观察同卵双胞胎的舌头，它们看起来会非常非常相似。顺便说一句，你可以观察舌头来判断某人是否是超级味觉者。你的听众可以通过去超市买蓝色食用色素来做这个实验。带回家，用棉签涂在舌头上，吞咽几次以移动染料。你的舌头，最好在带手电筒的放大镜下观察。你会看到粉红色的
circles against a blue background. Those pink circles are fungiform papilli. They're structures that hold taste buds. And you'll see that some people have a huge number of them. Their tongues look like they're absolutely tiled with these pink circles. And then there are others like me. I'm not a super taster. And for me, those pink circles are like polka dots. There's a lot of space between them. So you can see by looking at the tongue whether you're really an extreme supertaster or not. You can't really see it. Most people are in the middle, but you can see it with the extremes. That sounds like a fun experiment to do at home.
圆圈衬托在蓝色背景上。那些粉红色的圆圈是菌状乳头。它们是容纳味蕾的结构。你会发现有些人拥有大量的这种结构。他们的舌头看起来就像完全铺满了这些粉红色的圆圈。然后还有像我这样的人。我不是超级味觉者。对我来说，那些粉红色的圆圈就像波点。它们之间有很大的空间。所以你可以通过观察舌头来判断你是否真的是一个极端的超级味觉者。你不能真正看到它。大多数人处于中间，但你可以通过极端情况看到它。这听起来像是一个在家做的有趣实验。
Oh, it's wonderful. Kids love this, by the way, for science projects. Yeah, that's a great idea. And how would being a supertaster relate to weight? I mean, you talked about, and possibly obesity or being overweight. You talked about maybe being a risk factor for not consuming enough fiber, but could it also relate to someone maybe being more overweight or obese because they might not be eating some of these healthier foods that aren't as tasty?
哦，这太棒了。顺便说一句，孩子们非常喜欢这个科学项目。是的，那是个好主意。成为超级味觉者与体重有什么关系？我的意思是，你谈到了，可能还有肥胖或超重。你谈到了这可能是纤维摄入不足的风险因素，但它是否也可能与某人可能更超重或肥胖有关，因为他们可能不吃一些不那么美味的健康食物？
Wouldn't you think so? We thought so early on, but in fact, obesity is not really connected with supertasting. If you look at weight differences, you can find some groups of people where there might be a slight weight difference. And when there is, usually the supertasters are thinner, but it's not a very big effect. Okay. That's interesting. I want to also touch on a point you mentioned a little while ago.
你不这么认为吗？我们早期也这么认为，但事实上，肥胖与超级味觉并没有真正的联系。如果你观察体重差异，你可以找到一些人群，他们之间可能存在轻微的体重差异。当存在差异时，通常超级味觉者更瘦，但这并不是一个很大的影响。好的。这很有趣。我还想谈谈你刚才提到的一个观点。
And you're talking about getting food poisoning or getting sick on some food, maybe as a baby. But, you know, this can happen throughout your life. So say you've got food poisoning from some food and you feel like you can never eat it again. Is there any way to overcome that? It's hard. Not making yourself sick? It's hard. It's one trial learning.
你谈到了食物中毒或吃某种食物生病，也许是在婴儿时期。但是，你知道，这可能发生在你的一生中。所以假设你因为某种食物食物中毒，你觉得你再也吃不下它了。有什么方法可以克服吗？这很难。不是让自己生病？这很难。这是一次性学习。
Consider, for example, a cancer patient who's going to get radiation therapy or chemotherapy. and some of these therapies make you nauseated. So that nausea is going to condition onto foods and make a lot of foods become disgusting. So picture the cancer patient surviving cancer, going home, hoping to eat his or her favorite meal, biting into it and finding it disgusting. This is rough. And one of my tasks in the clinical world is to talk to patients like this and explain that In fact, this is the biology of food aversions.
考虑一下，例如，一个即将接受放射治疗或化学治疗的癌症患者。其中一些疗法会让你感到恶心。所以那种恶心感会条件反射到食物上，使很多食物变得令人作呕。所以想象一下癌症患者幸存下来，回家，希望能吃他或她最喜欢的饭菜，咬一口却发现它令人作呕。这很艰难。我在临床世界中的任务之一是与这样的病人交谈，并解释说，事实上，这就是食物厌恶的生物学原理。
The way to get over such an aversion, it's a conditioning effect, so you try to extinguish it. That is, try to eat the food that you've had trouble with when you're really feeling good. And if you're lucky, and you repeat this a few times, you may be able to extinguish the aversion. But I have to tell you, it's rugged. I developed an aversion to maraschino cherries, sitting, eating them in the best. back of the car, driving to California on a vacation, I was reading comic books and I was car sick. That aversion is so powerful that I cannot eat those things today. If I get one on a plate, I hope nobody's looking and I just shove it off the edge. I don't even want to see it.
克服这种厌恶的方法，它是一种条件反射效应，所以你要尝试消除它。也就是说，尝试在你感觉非常好时吃那些让你感到困扰的食物。如果你幸运的话，重复几次，你也许能够消除这种厌恶。但我必须告诉你，这很艰难。我对自己产生了对马拉斯奇诺樱桃的厌恶，坐在车后座吃它们，开车去加利福尼亚度假，我在看漫画书，我晕车了。那种厌恶感如此强烈，以至于我今天无法吃那些东西。如果我的盘子里有一个，我希望没人看着，我就把它推到边缘。我甚至不想看到它。
Yeah, so it's so tied into, like we're talking before about, you know, the smell and the whole experience is tied into your memories. And if that nausea memory is so strong, it's very difficult to overcome that. Very, very difficult. Does that same principle apply to Savior trying to get yourself to like some food that you want to like but struggle with, whether that be mushrooms, Brussels, sprouts, that sort of thing? Can you apply that same technique? It's easier to learn to like a food than it is to get over an aversion. That is, if you're completely neutral to something, as I said before, your best bet. First of all, simple exposure will help.
是的，所以它与我们之前谈到的嗅觉和整个体验与你的记忆联系在一起。如果那种恶心的记忆如此强烈，克服它非常困难。非常非常困难。同样的原则是否适用于你试图让自己喜欢某种你想喜欢但又很挣扎的食物，无论是蘑菇、抱子甘蓝之类的东西？你能应用同样的技术吗？学习喜欢一种食物比克服厌恶更容易。也就是说，如果你对某样东西完全中立，正如我之前所说，你最好的选择。首先，简单的接触会有帮助。
That is just eat it a few times. Don't eat a lot of it, but just eat it. You'll probably find yourself coming to like it. But if you want to speed that up, like with a kid who's finicky, put something good on it. It's like we said with the broccoli, sprinkle little sugar on, put some cheese on it. It'll help. And speaking of disgust, we kind of touched on that as well. Are there any foods that discussed nearly everybody?
也就是说，多吃几次。不要吃太多，但只要吃。你可能会发现自己开始喜欢它了。但如果你想加快这个过程，比如对于一个挑食的孩子，在上面加点好吃的。就像我们说西兰花那样，撒点糖，加点奶酪。这会有帮助。说到厌恶，我们也谈到了这一点。有没有什么食物让几乎所有人都感到厌恶？
I mean, I know that we've talked before about some of these foods that are cultural, It's something people had growing up, like vegemite or durians. But is there anything that's universally panned? You know, the person to ask about that is Paul Rosen. He's the disgust expert. And I think he has found that there are disgusting foods that are disgusting to a lot of people. And they often have an animal origin like feces or a decaying body, something like this. So there are certain things that we do culturally tend to be really disgusted.
我的意思是，我知道我们之前谈过一些文化上的食物，这是人们从小就吃的东西，比如维吉麦酱或榴莲。但有没有什么是普遍被否定的？你知道，问那个问题的最佳人选是保罗·罗森。他是厌恶专家。我认为他发现确实有一些令人作呕的食物，对很多人来说都是令人作呕的。它们通常具有动物起源，比如粪便或腐烂的尸体，类似这样的东西。所以确实有一些东西我们在文化上往往会感到非常厌恶。
But then again, disgust is also learned by these conditioned diversions. It's very easy to develop a disgust for something if you've eaten it and gotten sick. I did this to myself on purpose once. I was coming down with a flu and I was nauseated. I drove home and I always go by Kentucky fried chicken, so I stopped off and bought my favorite, all dark meat, extra crispy and ate it while I was nauseated. Now, I knew what I was doing, but I still developed. the aversion. And it was very powerful. For a while, I found myself not even driving by Kentucky
但话又说回来，厌恶感也是通过这些条件反射式的转移习得的。如果你吃过某种东西并因此生病，就很容易对它产生厌恶感。我曾经故意对自己做过这种实验。当时我快要感冒了，感到恶心。我开车回家，路过肯德基，于是我停下车，买了最喜欢的全黑肉、超脆炸鸡，在恶心的状态下把它吃了下去。当时我知道自己在做什么，但我还是产生了厌恶感。而且这种感觉非常强烈。有一段时间，我甚至发现自己连肯德基都不想路过。
fried chicken. And even now, if I want extra crispy, all dark meat, I buy it at Popeyes. I don't go to Kentucky Fried Chicken. So these aversions are powerful, and they take over. And it's important to have some compassion for people who've experienced these. And this is one of the things I feel about people who have real food dislikes. It's not something to make fun of. It's something that produces real distress. And I really don't believe in giving kids a hard time if they don't want to eat something they find disgusting. Yeah, you do raise a good point.
更别提去吃炸鸡了。即使是现在，如果我想吃超脆的全黑肉炸鸡，我也会去大力水手炸鸡（Popeyes）买。我不会去肯德基。所以这些厌恶感非常强大，而且会占据主导地位。对于那些经历过这些的人，保持同情心很重要。这也是我对那些真正有食物厌恶的人的看法。这不是什么可以拿来开玩笑的事情。这是一种会产生真正痛苦的事情。我真的不赞成在孩子们不想吃他们觉得恶心的东西时为难他们。是的，你提到了一个很好的观点。
I mean, instead of some people, you know, are picky eaters for whatever reason, it might be stressful for them to go into a situation like a party or a restaurant where they struggle to find something they like and don't want to also be singled out in the crowd for getting something, quote unquote, boring. So yeah, that's a good point, though, to be sensitive to that and try not to push people. Because like you said, it does have a stress component to it. By the way, a food anthropologist told me a wonderful excuse to make if you don't want to eat something, suggest you have an allergy to it or that that particular food is something that makes you sick. Mostly, that's a social explanation that works for people. And I actually
我的意思是，有些人因为各种原因比较挑食，去参加聚会或去餐厅对他们来说可能压力很大，因为他们很难找到自己喜欢的东西，而且也不想因为点了一些所谓的“无聊”食物而在人群中被另眼相待。所以，是的，这是一个很好的观点，要对这一点保持敏感，尽量不要强迫别人。因为正如你所说，这确实带有压力成分。顺便说一下，一位食物人类学家告诉我一个很好的借口，如果你不想吃某种东西，就说你对它过敏，或者说那种特定的食物会让你生病。大多数情况下，这是一个对人们有效的社交解释。而且我实际上
have seen some children who turned out to be extreme supertaste. and I took pictures of their tongues and gave them copies to take back to show their friends and told them that they've now heard from an expert that it's not healthy to eat foods you don't like. That's a great idea. It makes the kids feel a little better. I love that. I'm not sure their parents agree, but I think it's important.
见过一些孩子，他们被证明是极端的“超级味觉者”。我给他们的舌头拍了照片，并给了他们副本带回去给朋友看，告诉他们现在已经从专家那里听说，吃自己不喜欢的食物是不健康的。那真是个好主意。这让孩子们感觉好多了。我很喜欢这个。我不确定他们的父母是否同意，但我认为这很重要。
Yeah, like that. Speaking of children, children seem to be more sensitive to food than adults. Is that true? and does taste change over a lifespan? That's a wonderful question. The truth is we're all born neophobic. That means we're worried about anything new. And that's a very important survival characteristic.
是的，就像那样。说到孩子，孩子似乎比成年人对食物更敏感。这是真的吗？味觉会随着寿命的增长而改变吗？这是一个非常好的问题。事实是，我们生来就有“新奇恐惧症”。这意味着我们担心任何新的东西。这是一种非常重要的生存特征。
You want to watch out for something you don't know anything about. You don't want to eat it unless you've learned it's safe. Well, in our culture, we learn it safe because our parents tell it. You know, even animals do that. For example, a rat pup will sniff its mother's mouth to tell what she's been eating. And that rat pup is very likely to go off and eat the food that has the same smell. So we socially teach people how to eat things that are safe. And culturally, we even label our food to make it safe.
你会想要提防你不了解的东西。除非你已经知道它是安全的，否则你不会想吃它。嗯，在我们的文化中，我们通过父母的教导来学习什么是安全的。你知道，甚至动物也会这样做。例如，幼鼠会嗅它母亲的嘴，以分辨她吃了什么。而那只幼鼠很有可能会去吃带有同样气味的食物。所以我们通过社交方式教导人们如何吃安全的东西。在文化上，我们甚至会给食物贴上标签，使其看起来安全。
That's what spices do for us. For example, typically, if you want to eat a food that reminds you of your homeland, if you're an immigrant, for example, you use the spices from home. And you put those even on a novel food, and you can make that novel food seem like it belongs more to that culturally safe food you grew up with. That's a great idea. I never thought about that. This is a learned behavior. I was also reading somewhere as I was researching this that babies in the womb might like, so if this example of the mother ate garlic, the baby can tolerate garlic and breast milk after they're born because they were able to taste it in the amionic fluid.
这就是香料对我们的作用。例如，通常情况下，如果你是一个移民，想吃让你想起家乡的食物，你会使用家乡的香料。即使是在一种新奇的食物上撒上这些香料，你也能让那种新奇的食物看起来更像是你从小吃惯的那种文化上安全的食物。那真是个好主意。我从来没想过这一点。这是一种习得的行为。我在研究这个的时候还读到，婴儿在子宫里可能就会有喜好，比如如果母亲吃了大蒜，婴儿出生后就能耐受母乳中的大蒜味，因为他们在羊水中就能尝到它。
You're talking about Julie Minello's work. That is brilliant research. Yes. Julie has shown that both volatiles that a baby can detect in amniotic fluid as well as in mother's milk will carry valence. That is, if you get mom to eat something special like carrots when she's pregnant, you may find that your newborn baby is more interested in eating carrots than if they never had the exposure. So amniotic fluid and mother's milk are ways to get an organism to like foods, both other mammals and humans. Yeah, that's really interesting. I'm actually pregnant right now, and I've been eating a lot of carrots and garlic.
你提到的是朱莉·米内洛（Julie Mennella）的研究。那是很棒的研究。是的。朱莉已经证明，婴儿在羊水以及母乳中能检测到的挥发性物质都带有“效价”。也就是说，如果你让妈妈在怀孕时吃一些特别的东西，比如胡萝卜，你可能会发现你的新生儿对吃胡萝卜比从未接触过胡萝卜的婴儿更感兴趣。所以羊水和母乳是让生物喜欢某种食物的方式，无论是其他哺乳动物还是人类。是的，这真的很有趣。我目前正好怀孕了，我一直在吃很多胡萝卜和大蒜。
So hopefully that bodes well for an adventurous eater in the future. We'll see. I guess I can keep you updated on that. Is there, does any specific gender have a better palate? I've heard anecdotally so that women have a better. palettes, they're better at tasting wine and all the different notes you can get off a glass of wine. Is that true? There's some truth to that. First of all, women have a more sensitive sense of taste, which is pretty fascinating. And if you consider the fact that what women eat affects a fetus, there's real biological wisdom to that. But more, remember that women, especially in our culture, and actually most cultures, have more experience in the kitchen. So they've learned. more about smells in particular. So having a woman be, say, a better wine taster probably has
希望这预示着未来会有一个爱冒险的食客。我们拭目以待。我想我可以随时向你更新这个情况。有没有哪种特定的性别味觉更好？我听说过一些传闻，说女性的味觉更好，她们更擅长品尝葡萄酒以及从一杯酒中品尝出所有不同的风味。这是真的吗？这其中确实有道理。首先，女性的味觉更灵敏，这非常迷人。如果你考虑到女性所吃的食物会影响胎儿这一事实，这其中确实有生物学上的智慧。但更重要的是，请记住，女性，特别是在我们的文化中，实际上在大多数文化中，在厨房里的经验更多。所以她们学到了更多关于气味的知识，尤其是气味。所以让女性成为，比如说，更好的品酒师，可能
something to do with the fact she's learned to identify so many odors because she's had more exposure to them. Now, anybody can get that exposure. And this is what wine tasting is all about. If you learn to become a better wine taster, the way you learn that is you learn to recognize specific volatiles that are associated with the things that are likely to be found in wine. Yeah, that's the interesting part of that. I have a friend who's into wine and he does some, you know, wine tastings for friends. And there's this wheel that talks about all the different tastes. And some of them can be amazing, like a fresh strawberry. Some of them can be downright disgusting, like cat urine that was on the wheel or rubber, you know, that kind of thing, that things you can taste in
与她学会了识别如此多的气味有关，因为她接触这些气味的机会更多。现在，任何人都可以获得这种接触。这就是品酒的全部意义所在。如果你想成为一名更好的品酒师，学习的方法就是学会识别与葡萄酒中可能出现的物质相关的特定挥发性物质。是的，这很有趣。我有一个喜欢葡萄酒的朋友，他会为朋友们举办一些品酒会。有一个轮盘图，上面列出了所有不同的味道。其中一些可能很棒，比如新鲜草莓的味道。有些可能非常令人作呕，比如轮盘上的猫尿味或橡胶味，你知道，就是那种东西，你在
wine. And I was just have what I've gotten through, you know, re-osmosis through the years is just that if you are into wine tasting, you want to sniff things like tobacco, leather, chalk, all these things so you can identify those flavors when you're, when you're sniffing the wine, when you're tasting it. That's right. And that wine aroma wheel is Anne Nobles. She's an expert in both the chemistry and psychophysics of wine. She's retired now. She's out in California. And she's the one that put real science into a lot of that. Yeah, and it's very fascinating. Like I said, I had no idea because I was thinking, you see these charts that say you can taste chalk or smoke in wine and like, like, how do, I guess we all know the smell of chalk from me growing up or whatnot, but of all
葡萄酒中能尝到的东西。我多年来通过渗透学习到的就是，如果你喜欢品酒，你会想要嗅闻烟草、皮革、粉笔之类的东西，这样当你嗅闻葡萄酒、品尝它时，你就能识别出这些味道。没错。那个葡萄酒香气轮盘是安·诺布尔（Ann Noble）的作品。她是葡萄酒化学和心理物理学方面的专家。她现在退休了，住在加利福尼亚州。正是她将真正的科学引入了其中的许多领域。是的，这非常迷人。就像我说的，我完全不知道，因为我在想，你看到这些图表说你可以在葡萄酒中尝到粉笔或烟味，就像，我想我们从小到大都知道粉笔的味道，但所有
the things, like, yeah, you have to kind of re-sniff that to be able to identify that in a glass of wine. But I didn't realize if you're training yourself in that, in that area that you should be smelling a lot of different things. That is correct. And you've, I want to talk about some of your research you've done. You've been involved in work to enhance the flavor of tombs. tomatoes. So why tomatoes? Well, we started with tomatoes because my colleague, Harry Clee, is one of the world's experts on tomato volatiles. And we began with the tomato because we wanted to make it more palatable. Now, I don't know if you've eaten supermarket tomatoes recently, but they leave a lot to be desired. Most people have a memory of a tomato that was really wonderful and a lot better
这些东西，是的，你必须重新嗅闻它才能在杯葡萄酒中识别出来。但我没意识到如果你在那个领域训练自己，你应该闻很多不同的东西。那是正确的。我想谈谈你做过的一些研究。你参与了增强番茄风味的工作。那么为什么要选番茄呢？嗯，我们从番茄开始，因为我的同事哈里·克利（Harry Klee）是世界上番茄挥发性物质方面的专家之一。我们从番茄开始，是因为我们想让它更可口。现在，我不知道你最近是否吃过超市里的番茄，但它们实在令人失望。大多数人对番茄的记忆是非常美妙的，比
than what you can usually buy in the supermarket. Well, part of the reason for that, is that we have raised tomatoes to ship. And if you want to breed tomatoes to have good shipping characteristics, you're not paying much attention to their flavor. So Harry wanted to make tomatoes more palatable, and also, tomatoes are healthy. So if we make them more palisible, can we improve the diet by getting people to eat more of something like a tomato
你通常在超市里买到的要好得多。嗯，部分原因是，我们培育番茄是为了运输。如果你想培育出具有良好运输特性的番茄，你就不会太关注它们的风味。所以哈里想让番茄更可口，而且番茄很健康。所以如果我们让它们更可口，我们能否通过让人们多吃像番茄这样
that's a healthy thing to eat? Well, it turns out it's not a very difficult problem. You really want to know what it is in the tomato that makes it like. Well, you do the chemistry on the tomatoes, and we actually grew at the University of Florida because we are a farm agricultural college, so we have farmland. We grew our own tomatoes and we grew heirloom tomatoes. Now, heirloom tomatoes, people think heirlooms are better tomatoes. They're not.
健康的东西来改善饮食呢？嗯，事实证明这并不是一个很难的问题。你真的想知道番茄里是什么让它变得受欢迎。嗯，你对番茄进行化学分析，我们实际上是在佛罗里达大学种植的，因为我们是一所农学院，所以我们有农田。我们种植了自己的番茄，也种植了传家宝番茄。现在，传家宝番茄，人们认为传家宝是更好的番茄。其实不然。
Airloom means they're genetically diverse. It refers to tomatoes that came before we started breeding and breeding. for shipping. Anyway, we grew heirloom tomatoes because they're genetically diverse. We did the chemistry on them, and we did the psychophysics. We measured both what they tasted and smelled like, and we measured how much people liked them. Turns out, you put all that together, and you put it into a regression model, which we were helped with by our colleague, Howard Moskowitz, and this regression model actually will give you the formula for the great tomato. Now, we could have created the best tomato in the world, but actually that's really, really hard to do because
“传家宝”意味着它们在基因上是多样化的。它指的是在我们开始为了运输而进行反复育种之前的番茄。总之，我们种植了传家宝番茄，因为它们在基因上是多样化的。我们对它们进行了化学分析，并进行了心理物理学测试。我们测量了它们的味道和气味，并测量了人们对它们的喜爱程度。事实证明，你把所有这些放在一起，放入一个回归模型中，我们的同事霍华德·莫斯科维茨（Howard Moskowitz）帮助了我们，这个回归模型实际上会给你提供完美番茄的配方。现在，我们本可以创造出世界上最好的番茄，但实际上这真的非常非常难，因为
it cars a lot of chemistry. Anyway, what we did do is determine which constituents in the tomato contributed what to palatibility so that we could create tomatoes that were better. And actually, Herrickley did create such a tomato. It's called a garden gem. And if you want to get seeds and grow that tomato, send him an email message and send a donation to his lab and I'll bet he'll give you some of his rare tomato seeds. Anyway, why did we start with tomatoes? Because they were there and it was easy. But we've now done the same work with strawberries and oranges and peaches and blueberries. And we know a very, very great deal about which constituents in fruit make them liked better. And we also know which volatiles in the fruit contribute to sweet.
它需要大量的化学知识。总之，我们所做的是确定番茄中的哪些成分对适口性有贡献，以便我们能够创造出更好的番茄。事实上，哈里·克利确实创造了这样一种番茄。它被称为“花园宝石”（Garden Gem）。如果你想获得种子并种植那种番茄，给他发一封电子邮件，并向他的实验室捐款，我敢打赌他会给你一些他珍稀的番茄种子。总之，我们为什么从番茄开始？因为它们就在那里，而且很容易。但我们现在已经在草莓、橙子、桃子和蓝莓上做了同样的工作。我们非常非常了解水果中的哪些成分能让它们更受欢迎。我们也知道水果中的哪些挥发性物质有助于产生甜味。
So it has more to do with transporting food than it is of the food itself. So, you know, I definitely have tasted some very disappointing tomatoes of the grocery store or when I have grown some outside, they're incredibly delicious. So it's fascinating that's really based on consumer needs in the grocery store. You know, the sad part about it is we've got the science to make almost anything we grow better. What you need to do is understand the economics. and you have to understand what the farmer is paid for and what he's going to grow. And unfortunately, a lot of farmers are paid for fruit or vegetables by wheat.
所以这更多地与运输食物有关，而不是食物本身。所以，你知道，我确实在杂货店尝过一些非常令人失望的番茄，或者当我在外面种一些时，它们非常美味。所以这真的基于杂货店消费者的需求，这很迷人。你知道，可悲的是，我们有科学技术让几乎所有我们种植的东西变得更好。你需要做的是了解经济学，你必须了解农民是为了什么而获得报酬，以及他将种植什么。不幸的是，许多农民是按重量获得水果或蔬菜报酬的。
And we don't insist that they become, that they be very palatable. If we insist on that, the breeders and the growers can produce it. We just have to insist on it. And those may be the ones you, and they might be a little more ripe, so you might have to eat them more quickly. If you get them from the grocery store, that might come. into play a little bit, correct? Yeah.
我们并不坚持要求它们必须非常可口。如果我们坚持这一点，育种者和种植者就能生产出来。我们只需要坚持这一点。而那些可能是你（喜欢的），而且它们可能更成熟一点，所以你可能需要更快地吃掉它们。如果你从杂货店买它们，这可能会有一点影响，对吧？是的。
Yep, that's called post-harvest. That is how you treat something is going to affect its flavor as well as the genetics of the plant. So you have to pay attention to all of it. Have you ever heard about how tomato juice tastes better on airplanes or people tend to order more V8 when they're on an airplane than they would on the ground? I've heard that and I know absolutely no good science that supports it. There are some papers on that, but they aren't very impressive. Maybe I haven't read them all.
是的，这叫“采后处理”。你处理东西的方式会影响它的风味，植物的遗传基因也会影响。所以你必须注意所有这些。你有没有听说过番茄汁在飞机上味道更好，或者人们在飞机上往往比在地面上点更多的V8蔬菜汁？我听说过，但我绝对不知道有什么好的科学依据支持它。有一些关于这个的论文，但它们并不令人印象深刻。也许我没有读过所有的论文。
But this notion is, I know, every so often it pops up online and it is not something that is generally understood and believed in by experts. So it's maybe more of a placebo effect. I'm not sure what it is. I shouldn't say absolutely it can't happen. There are the same kinds of stories come from submarines. The same things come from our astronauts. do things taste different to them when they're in outer space? Unfortunately, we haven't done a lot of research on that.
但这个概念是，我知道，它时不时地在网上出现，这不是专家们普遍理解和相信的东西。所以它可能更多的是一种安慰剂效应。我不确定它是什么。我不应该说它绝对不可能发生。有同样的故事来自潜艇。同样的事情也来自我们的宇航员。当他们在太空中时，东西的味道对他们来说会有所不同吗？不幸的是，我们没有对此做过很多研究。
But in fact, there's not a lot of really solid evidence for it. However, if anybody's got some evidence, I'm happy to look. Yeah, that would be open up some new areas of research, too, like you said, if we're going into space, underground, that sort of thing. Maybe it's also people are just ordering Bloody Mary's or something. Or they wish they had a Bloody Mary on the plane? Well, I think that most of the people who are getting tomato juice on the plane, I mean, they're probably getting alcohol in it.
但事实上，并没有很多真正可靠的证据支持它。然而，如果有人有证据，我很乐意看看。是的，那也会开辟一些新的研究领域，就像你说的，如果我们进入太空、地下等等。也许这只是因为人们在飞机上点血腥玛丽（Bloody Mary）之类的东西。或者他们希望在飞机上能喝到血腥玛丽？嗯，我认为大多数在飞机上喝番茄汁的人，我的意思是，他们可能在里面加了酒精。
That probably has a little bit to do with their judgment. Yeah, that could be true too. It tastes better. For those experiments you're talking about with strawberries and oranges, is that because maybe strawberries are picked too soon? Because when I thought of like, you know, an orange or a strawberry, I typically thought, you know, if you get them at the right time of year at their grocery store, they're pretty good.
这可能与他们的判断力有一点关系。是的，那也可能是真的。味道更好。对于你谈到的那些关于草莓和橙子的实验，是不是因为草莓可能采摘得太早了？因为当我想到，你知道，橙子或草莓时，我通常认为，如果你在一年中的正确时间在杂货店买到它们，它们相当不错。
But is the same concern there with, you know, we're focusing on asking farmers to give it to us by weight and we're worried about shipping. We're not concerned about the taste. There's a lot of interest in making good things, making strawberries good. And wow, we know a lot about that now because we know which volatiles in the strawberries make them sweeter. And in fact, there are about 30 some volatiles in a tomato that all add a little bit of sweetness to it. Because those volatiles, when we bite into the strawberry, the message travels to the same part of the brain that codes for the sweetness of sugar. and those volatiles enhance the sweetness message in the brain.
但同样的担忧是否存在，你知道，我们专注于要求农民按重量给我们，我们担心运输。我们不关心味道。人们对制造好东西、让草莓变得好吃非常感兴趣。哇，我们现在对此了解很多，因为我们知道草莓中的哪些挥发性物质使它们更甜。事实上，番茄中有大约30多种挥发性物质，它们都增加了一点甜味。因为当我们咬草莓时，这些挥发性物质的信息会传到大脑中编码糖分甜味的部分，而这些挥发性物质增强了大脑中的甜味信息。
Now, once you've identified those volatiles, you can take them out of the strawberry and put them in pure sugar and it'll get sweeter. So this is one of the things I'm very excited about right now because it looks like about the safest way to make a so-called artificial sweet that could possibly exist. We use volatiles that we've already been eating ever since humans were humans. and they're going to, if you pick the right volatiles, they're going to produce sweetness in the brain. Now, first of all, you can certainly breed for those volatiles in the strawberry, and you're going to produce strawberries that do not need any sugar. I have tasted some of these strawberries, and I'm telling you, when they're widely available, people are really going to like them.
现在，一旦你确定了这些挥发性物质，你就可以把它们从草莓中提取出来，放入纯糖中，它会变得更甜。所以这是我现在非常兴奋的事情之一，因为它看起来是目前可能存在的最安全的制造所谓“人工甜味”的方法。我们使用人类自古以来就一直在吃的挥发性物质。而且，如果你选择了正确的挥发性物质，它们会在大脑中产生甜味。现在，首先，你当然可以为了这些挥发性物质而培育草莓，你将生产出不需要任何糖的草莓。我尝过一些这样的草莓，我告诉你，当它们被广泛使用时，人们真的会喜欢它们。
But at the same time, we can put these volatiles in anything that we want to be sweeter, and we can make it sweeter safely for, let's say, diabetics. But there's something else about it that I'm very excited about. I've spent a lot of my career studying people who have taste damage. And one of the things about using volatiles to affect a taste message in the brain is those volatiles bypass damaged nerves. That is, if your taste nerve is damaged, you can't perceive more sweet from sugar because you don't have the nerve to carry the message. But if you consume sugar that has some of these volatiles in that enhance sweet, those are going to, the volatiles, the message is going to bypass the damaged nerve and increase the sweet message in the brain. And I'm happy to say that the early test with patients supports this. It looks like it's going to work. Would those enhancements be considered genetically modified?
但与此同时，我们可以把这些挥发性物质放入任何我们想要变甜的东西中，我们可以安全地让它变甜，比如为糖尿病患者。但关于它还有另一件事让我非常兴奋。我的职业生涯中花了很多时间研究味觉受损的人。使用挥发性物质来影响大脑中的味觉信息的好处之一是，这些挥发性物质绕过了受损的神经。也就是说，如果你的味觉神经受损，你就无法从糖中感知到更多的甜味，因为你没有神经来传递信息。但如果你摄入含有一些能增强甜味的挥发性物质的糖，那些挥发性物质的信息将绕过受损的神经，增加大脑中的甜味信息。我很高兴地说，与患者的早期测试支持了这一点。看起来它会奏效。这些增强会被认为是基因改造吗？
No, no. Organisms? Okay. Nobody does that today. Well, not nobody. But the fact is there's so much prejudice. against genetic modified. And I have to tell you, I am not a supporter of that prejudice. If we want to feed the world, we want to use the best science we've got. And if we can genetically modify something to make it, put up, say, a vitamin in rice that's going to save children in the third world from going blind, I say all for it. And I know of no evidence that genetically modified organisms are in any way dangerous. I think that's a type of prejudice that's gotten into
不，不。生物？好的。今天没人那样做。嗯，不是没人。但事实是，对基因改造存在太多的偏见。我必须告诉你，我不是这种偏见的支持者。如果我们想养活世界，我们想使用我们拥有的最好的科学。如果我们能通过基因改造某种东西，比如在水稻中加入一种维生素，从而拯救第三世界的儿童免于失明，我举双手赞成。而且我不知道有任何证据表明基因改造生物在任何方面是危险的。我认为这是一种进入了
the world. I don't know how it got there and I'm sorry it's there because I think it's doing a lot of harm. Yeah, I've definitely, I mean, there's a lot of arguments against it, but I've heard more than one person say your side of it and typically someone who's a researcher in the science field saying like if we can feed people out there who otherwise wouldn't be able to get the nutrition they need, then we need to think about that. We sure do. And also I wanted to touch on your burning mouth syndrome. So I'm sure most people who are listening have all burned their mouths on food and know how annoying it is. Your tongue goes numb and nothing really tastes great for a couple of days.
世界的偏见。我不知道它是怎么产生的，我很遗憾它存在，因为我认为它正在造成很大的伤害。是的，我绝对，我的意思是，有很多反对它的论点，但我听过不止一个人说你的那一面，通常是科学领域的研究人员说，如果我们能养活那些否则无法获得所需营养的人，那么我们需要考虑这一点。我们确实需要。而且我还想谈谈你的“灼口综合征”。所以我相信大多数听众都曾因食物烫伤过嘴，知道那有多烦人。你的舌头会麻木，几天内什么东西尝起来都不太好。
But for some people that doesn't go away. And so your lab uncovered the reasons why people suffer from this. So can you explain what the causes of burning mouth syndrome are and how many people might have it and how you can be treated? Burning mouth syndrome actually has nothing to do with damage in the mouth. Burning mouth syndrome occurs in the brain. It's what we call a sensory phantom. You can make a phantom in any sensory nerve in the body. Have you ever heard of a phantom limb? Yes. This is feeling and arm is there after it's been amputated. Well, you can have a phantom smell, a phantom taste, and a phantom pain in your tongue. So how does it happen? We think what causes it is, believe it or not, damage to the taste. nerve, the seventh cranial nerve, that nerve normally has two jobs. It both brings taste information to the brain, but it also terminates oral pain, maybe even pain on other parts of the body. Now, think about why that might be a good idea. Imagine an animal in the wild fighting to
但对一些人来说，这种情况不会消失。所以你的实验室揭示了人们遭受这种痛苦的原因。那么你能解释一下灼口综合征的原因是什么，有多少人可能患有这种病，以及如何治疗吗？灼口综合征实际上与口腔损伤无关。灼口综合征发生在大脑中。这就是我们所说的“感觉幻觉”。你可以在身体的任何感觉神经中制造幻觉。你听说过“幻肢”吗？是的。这就是在手臂被截肢后感觉手臂还在。嗯，你可以有幻嗅、幻味和舌头上的幻痛。那么它是怎么发生的呢？我们认为导致它的原因是，信不信由你，味觉神经（第七对脑神经）的损伤，那条神经通常有两个工作。它既将味觉信息带到大脑，也终止口腔疼痛，甚至可能是身体其他部位的疼痛。现在，想想为什么这可能是一个好主意。想象一只在野外为
survive with its teeth. It's going to get bitten on some occasions, and another animal might bite it. it might bite its own tongue, and if tongue pain stops it from eating, an animal's going to die. So a survival characteristic would be to somehow stop the pain of any kind of oral damage. Well, if the animal takes a bite of food and the food input, the sensory input, inhibits the pain, it's going to eat and survive. It looks like that mechanism connected the taste system to pain. So what happens is if you damage taste, you lose the ability of taste to inhibit pain. And essentially, pain turns on in the brain.
生存而战的动物。它偶尔会被咬伤，另一只动物可能会咬它。它可能会咬到自己的舌头，如果舌头疼痛阻止它进食，动物就会死亡。所以一种生存特征将是设法阻止任何形式的口腔损伤的疼痛。嗯，如果动物咬了一口食物，食物的输入，即感觉输入，抑制了疼痛，它就会进食并生存下来。看起来那个机制将味觉系统与疼痛连接了起来。所以发生的情况是，如果你损伤了味觉，你就失去了味觉抑制疼痛的能力。本质上，疼痛在大脑中被开启了。
It's like you flip to switch and you can't reach it to turn it off. Now, how can you get rid of the phantom? And by the way, let me tell you how we discovered that the phantom was in the brain. If you had a burnt mouth, it would be easy to treat it. All you'd have to do is anesthetize the area of the burn. and the pain will go away. When we anesthetize the tongues of people with burning mouth syndrome, the burn gets worse. Why does it get worse?
就像你拨动了一个开关，却够不着把它关掉。那么，你如何摆脱这种幻觉呢？顺便说一下，让我告诉你我们是如何发现幻觉在大脑中的。如果你有烫伤的嘴，治疗它会很容易。你所要做的就是麻醉烫伤区域，疼痛就会消失。当我们麻醉灼口综合征患者的舌头时，灼烧感反而加重了。为什么会加重？
Because the burn is only occurring in people with damage to taste. And when we anesthetize their tongues, we take out whatever taste was left and we make the effects of the damage worse. So the pain phantom in the brain gets worse. Now, that goes away when the anesthetic wears off, fortunately. but you don't have just burn phantoms in the mouth. You can have taste phantoms and you can have touch phantoms. For example, you could wake up one morning with a bitter taste in your mouth that never went away. Believe me, you would not be happy.
因为这种灼烧感只发生在味觉受损的人身上。当我们麻醉他们的舌头时，我们去掉了仅存的味觉，使损伤的影响加重了。所以大脑中的疼痛幻觉加重了。现在，幸运的是，当麻醉剂失效时，这种情况会消失。但你不仅在口腔中有灼烧幻觉。你还可以有味觉幻觉和触觉幻觉。例如，你可能某天早上醒来，嘴里有一种永远不会消失的苦味。相信我，你不会开心的。
And so can it be treated? Yes, it can. And I can tell you, one of the reasons that I got so interested in this was my father had lung cancer when I was in college and his most distressing symptom was a metallic taste in his mouth that wouldn't go away. And we didn't know what to do for him at that time. But one of the reasons I got interested in Phantoms was to try to figure out how to help patients. It turns out we can use a medication that intensifies inhibitory neurotransmitters in the brain. It's called a GABA agonist.
那么它能被治疗吗？是的，可以。我可以告诉你，我之所以对这个如此感兴趣，原因之一是我上大学时我父亲患了肺癌，他最痛苦的症状是嘴里有一种挥之不去的金属味。当时我们不知道该为他做什么。但我对幻觉产生兴趣的原因之一是试图找出如何帮助患者。事实证明，我们可以使用一种能增强大脑中抑制性神经递质的药物。它被称为“GABA激动剂”。
And a GABA agonist will restore some of the brain. that inhibition from taste that was lost from damage, and it will reduce that burn phantom in about 60, 70 percent of patients. And I can't take the credit for that. That was discovered by Dr. Miriam Grushka, who is an oral pathology expert. Yeah, it sounds like a really troubling situation that can happen, but it's nice to know there's at least a solution for people, like you said, not just me burning mouth, having a metallic taste, or that's, I mean, that really can inhibit the quality of your life if you have a bad taste in your life. It's nice to know. mouth all the time. It is, it is awful. It's one of, it's one of the reasons why that's the
GABA激动剂将恢复大脑中因损伤而失去的部分味觉抑制，它将减少大约60%到70%患者的灼烧幻觉。我不能把功劳归于自己。那是米里亚姆·格鲁什卡（Miriam Grushka）博士发现的，她是一位口腔病理学专家。是的，这听起来是一个非常令人困扰的情况，但很高兴知道至少有一个解决方案，就像你说的，不仅仅是灼口，还有金属味，或者那，我的意思是，如果你生活中一直有糟糕的味道，那真的会抑制你的生活质量。很高兴知道。一直都在嘴里。确实，确实很糟糕。这就是为什么这是我
specialty area that I work on in taste pathology, because it probably produces more distress for patients than any other taste problem. Yeah, because the quality of, you know, the quality of life, the enjoyment of food, it's just everything. I mean, you're living with that every second of every day. It's just like having a disturbing taste in your mouth. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Bartich. This has been a really fascinating conversation and I'm probably going to head out to the grocery store and get some of that blue dye and test out that experiment you mentioned earlier today. That sounds like a lot of fun. Do you do that at parties? You know, the truth is I actually have done it at lectures. I take paper with me that is bitter to
在味觉病理学领域工作的专业领域，因为它可能比任何其他味觉问题给患者带来更多的痛苦。是的，因为生活质量，对食物的享受，这简直是一切。我的意思是，你每天每秒都在忍受它。这就像嘴里有一种令人不安的味道。好吧，非常感谢你加入我们，巴蒂奇博士。这是一次非常迷人的谈话，我可能会去杂货店买一些那种蓝色染料，测试一下你今天早些时候提到的那个实验。听起来很有趣。你在聚会上做那个吗？你知道，事实是，我确实在讲座中做过。我随身带着对
super tasters and pick the people in the audience who think the paper is just awful and put blue food coloring on and let everybody look at their tongue. That's a lot of fun. That's a really great idea. a good thing to do with kids. But thanks again so much for your time. It's been a real pleasure speaking with you. I'm delighted. And thank you for being so well prepared. I really enjoyed this.
超级味觉者来说很苦的纸，挑选观众中觉得纸的味道非常糟糕的人，涂上蓝色食用色素，让大家看看他们的舌头。那很有趣。那真是个好主意。和孩子们一起做是件好事。但再次非常感谢你的时间。和你交谈真是太愉快了。我很高兴。也谢谢你准备得如此充分。我真的很享受这次谈话。
Before we go, just a reminder to let you know, we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue, about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology.
在我们离开之前，提醒大家，我们想听到你们的声音。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。此外，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。Speaking of Psychology 是 APA 播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，如 APA Journal's Dialogue（关于新的心理学研究）和 Progress Notes（关于心理学实践）。
You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website speakingofpsychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。